hello everyone welcome to simulation I'm
your host Don sake and today we have the
pleasure of sitting down with Dan gaily
hey how's it going thanks for having me
thank you for coming on yeah
dan is the founder of synapse AI they
are a decentralized AI network and we'll
be talking a lot about decentralization
the AI economy and what this all means
today and for the future yeah so your
background very interdisciplinary I
didn't I didn't think there would be
some chemistry and some robotics and
some oil and gas yeah there's a little
there's a little bit of everything in
there yeah walk us through some of it so
I grew up just programming okay I
started programming when I was about 10
years old I think I'm the black sheep my
father was a lawyer my mother was a
nurse I just saw computers as like this
amazing new thing I grew up in the
hacking and freaking scene so went into
a chat room somewhere and asked somebody
to teach me how to hack right which is
like the most naive question like who
can teach me how to hack and somebody
actually just taught me how to program
and so they kind of tricked me into that
and which is the best trick I've ever
you know I've ever had pulled on me and
from there I ended up skipping a grade
graduating and going into research and
development in the telecom industry so I
had a friend that his father owned a
telecom company and he asked me if I was
still hacking in essence and I was like
sure and went to go work there in
Houston yeah yeah
and then this is so great so okay so
your involvement in computer science in
hacking is was kind of a foundation for
you moving forward and then what what
else led you to the sort of idea of
wanting to get involved in
decentralization and they
economy so after in my early 20s I had
like a punk rock band and I hosted a
poetry night and you know there was a
lot of like self-discovery happening I
ended up going back to school and
basically doing electrical engineering
with a focus and autonomous robotics and
computational chemistry was another one
of my degrees and so I got exposed to
machine learning models and basic models
of computation as well as robotics right
machine learning model showed that and
from there I decided to move out to San
Francisco and what was that sohow
because I'm always fascinated by the
reasons why people decide to make the
move so I grew up on IRC all of my
friends were on IRC is a chat right and
it's a it's kind of the precursor to
what slack is now and things like that
and all my friends in the hacking scene
were already in the Bay Area
mm-hmm so I knew I was gonna move out
eventually right and when it finally
came time and I felt like I was really
had all the tools that I wanted to have
to come out here I just decided okay
well this is the next step and funny
enough I I was like okay I could either
be a stand-up comedian in New York and
try Fresno because I like to consider
myself a funny guy right yeah or just
you know move out there so looking Bali
and do my own thing so that was like the
crossroads yeah and I flipped the
quarter and it was like build the future
of everything yeah but I can make people
laugh along the way so yeah that's great
it's funny a crucial skill for people
skills yeah so all right so tell us
about you what what year was that you
came out here and how did you decide to
found companies and what was the first
one second one yeah
the year was 2010 and I basically packed
up my Honda Civic with everything that I
could fit inside of it and I didn't have
a place to stay a job lined up and I
think I had like $2,000 of my
right I love it yeah I love it necessity
is the mother of invention right yeah
and so I moved out here and immediately
got my first job and the whole the whole
catalyst was you know I've always wanted
to build my own software company I know
that's a it's like what do you ask you
know children what they want to be when
they grow up mine was like an inventor
or like you know I want to own a
software company my my heroes were kind
of the Bill Gates and Steve Jobs right
of the that era because that's what I
grew up in and so I knew that's what I
wanted to do right and I didn't know to
what effect but I knew this is where
this is a place where it happens and so
I came out here and basically sold my
car had another four grand right but in
San Francisco that's like two months and
I ended up renting a room and decided
that if I'm going to build something I
should learn how to build startups first
right I should learn how to go companies
and so I got a job and my job was
basically like normalization of entities
online and I think our next the next
best thing that compares to was like
metaweb that Google buy so they would
basically scrape all the entities online
and like build ontology zuv people
places and things right and that was my
first job out here cool previously I had
been an intern at the National Center
for physical acoustics building sensors
for nuclear weapons testing well around
the world yeah so it was pretty exciting
but software is where I belong right
ultimately and then hung out in that
first startup for a little bit it was
really cool got to do a lot of like
cutting-edge stuff and decided that I
wanted to try my own thing you have like
a lot of people trying something big for
the first time it often explodes in your
face which is you know which is a good
thing I think if you're not trying
and things think should fail
spectacularly if they are to fill in
anyway alright so that was a we were
doing one big menu because at the time I
was like the world is one big menu and I
wouldn't find the best tiramisu in the
world right so the whole impetus for
this was just to find the best tiramisu
in the world so I wanted to give like
dish level reviews and I think
Foodspotting was of an app that was out
at the time that just had launched so
they were kind of in the same space and
that just like fell apart because team
and there's so many parameters that go
into executing not just on an idea but
also to carry the company that you learn
a lot of lessons while you're building
these things right and ice burner strips
the best thing you'll ever do
simultaneously the worst thing I yeah
it's it's been you be careful what you
wish for but you'll never want to you'll
never feel more rewarded doing anything
else I think ok so there's a lot of
great lessons but when you've learned
your lessons and you've graduated and
learning bigger lessons you kind of have
the ability to take a look back and go
wow like look how far I've come in this
amount of yeah right so I think
ultimately the lesson there is just to
keep trying yep right but I moved to the
valley and there were two things on my
mind one I'll never build social
networks right ah - I'll never build AI
yeah yeah I thought it you know I was
like okay this is the thing and this was
before it was really popular and I it
was we were still kind of in a big
winter for that even though personally I
love statistics and I love data science
and whatever other kind of terminologies
that people came up to talk about
machine learning and AI without actually
talking about it right but I kind of
felt like there was a lot of an enable
gazing at the time with like
or armchair kind of ideas of what it
would what could be possible had we had
a I as opposed to building it yeah I'm
so I ended up running the San Francisco
hacker news meet up and hacker news
mm-hmm
hacker News's Y Combinator's kind of
psyched right it's like their version of
Reddit yep it's a cool site yeah it is
it serves a very particular demographic
right which is like the the the hacker
yeah for its namesake right and the
entrepreneur and you know they kind of
help critique as best as possible one
another's work and it's where you find
out a lot about the latest of what's
happening you ain't funny story is
before I moved out here I applied to be
the co-founder of uber which was yeah
funny funny story and that's maybe a
different story so coming out here I ran
the San Francisco hacker news Meetup and
that's where I got exposed to
cryptocurrencies and Bitcoin in
particular so in the intermediary I was
like you know kind of running my own
startups and trying to figure that out
oh so my second set up was a social
network it was like legitimately when
you're riding a bike trying not to hit a
tree the only thing you're going to hit
is that tree right so I I I in essence
looked back and said okay what skills do
I have what problems have I seen and
being right out of college
immediately I tried to you know fix
those problems right so I was head of
our robotics team and we went to
competition and I made an up you college
yes in law school
and I also started my high school
Computer Club - so my nerd cred right
yeah and you know I look back and I saw
that the teams that had the the most
funding were the teams that did well you
know they were able to create more
experiments and and
they just had more resources ultimately
so the first network that I built was
called schoolyard and it was a way for
alumni to connect with students to crowd
fund essentially continuously crowd fund
student projects right and and student
groups and it's crucial it is you could
actually be able to tinker and invent
into the world to get the funding from
alumni mentors right yep
and you can also use that as a kind of a
springboard into your own career and you
know you can keep everyone in the loop
with what is actually happening at their
alma mater so yep yep I think it what is
that doing
does it still know it's dead it's dead
yeah so a lot of a couple of the things
you built are dead couple are still
alive and thriving for every one thing I
launched there was like a hundred things
that never dated that it was you know is
just like I'm pretty much a machine when
it comes to like ideas and building
stuff right but fundamentally over time
you start trying to observe the reason
for building and you have more time to
think about the impact of how you're
spending your time yep right so I built
a couple of these things I ended up
working in venture capital as Annie I
are entrepreneur and resident and my job
was basically to facilitate dill flow
for crypto companies cool right this was
2013
I think and we we went out and I
basically had the opportunity to meet
some of the brightest people that were
deciphering what crypto meant and what
the centralization meant and what what
just the impact of all of this on the
future was right and I made a bunch of
friends and went out to the first
Bitcoin conference in San Jose really
great you know the Winklevoss twins were
just walking around coinbase had just
started I had a meeting funny enough I
had a meeting with Bryan CEO of coinbase
because he posted on Hacker News if
somebody was interested in co-founding a
new crypto currency exchange
came to be coinbase which was cool yep
so you had all these like early players
that were just like figuring out where
they fit yep right and then I worked in
venture capital and I took a step back
and I I kind of looked at my research
and looked at where cryptid was headed
and and we started talking about these
things in terms of programmatic money
write in machine money terms right what
happens not just when humans are trading
these days but when you have these
commodities and resources and assets
that these agents have agency over and
they're able to transact with one
another right through cryptocurrency
mm-hmm so I started investigating that
and thinking about that and I think
simultaneously I threw a hackathon
called hack endo and it was about
getting companies out so I've done a ton
right so getting companies out that had
IOT applications and devices and talking
about kind of more what happens when we
have these these services right and what
emergent products we can build when we
start mashing these things up yep so
really starting to think about
multi-agent systems heterogeneous
systems and how they can transact with
one another and contract one another and
facilitate this kind of ambient
intelligent world mm-hmm
that led to right that's the good stuff
yeah that's what I'm sitting back and
I'm like oh if what we're at now is me
and my devices right and how they work
together then in the future where we'll
be as me my devices you and your devices
and how they all talk and work together
yeah right and that kind of brings in
this this idea of the sharing economy
and and when machines and sensors can
talk in this open kind of ecosystem and
garden of devices and oceans of sensor
data models that are being built and
came out with something called playa
which this is like super insider info
came out with something called Playa and
had to pitch this idea of connecting all
this is like pre aetherium right I think
connecting all these things in a very
decentralized way and I had so that you
can contract resources out and the
example that I gave I was actually asked
to pitch at a conference and they they
picked me out as one of the best of the
demo Pitts kind of crew and came out to
pitch and I said well in the future and
anytime you start like that conversation
in the future when you're talking to
investors are already like okay what so
so you don't have anything ready right
now right and I said well in the future
you'll step out of your your autonomous
vehicle it'll look for recharge it'll
try to find a recharging station it'll
negotiate a recharge on your behalf and
then it'll contract itself out as an
uber exactly right it's a great example
right yeah and it'll make money while
you sleep right so that was a really
great example especially after many many
many nights of thinking about how to how
to phrase this or how to even speak
about these things to people and I
remember the judges very distinctly
saying you're either crazy or you're a
genius and we're not sure which and I
step up geniuses start crazy and then
everyone's like damn they were right
right and I step off stage and my friend
goes why can't you be both and I'm just
like great thank you I appreciate it but
when I got back to my booth you know I
think the this VP of IOT at Cisco came
up to me and representatives from NTT
DoCoMo from GE all of these huge the
Department of Defense all these huge
companies and huge firms were already
thinking about this right and and
figuring out what that future is going
to start looking like so that they can
build start building the infrastructure
and support so that was kind of one of
the moments where I was just like ah
yeah ah ha like I'm not alone yep right
yep and and that's a huge sign when the
multinational conglomerates
are approaching you and saying that oh
we're also thinking about this field in
the future there a right in the future
yeah so it's time to capitalize now yeah
yeah absolutely and so I went back to
some my friends in venture capital and I
was like look this is gonna be what's
happening next like I just know it and
they say cool we have no idea what
you're talking about
and I'm like great so what we've got a
simple example of them they should be
like okay I guess that makes sense and
yeah yeah yeah the thomas vehicle has to
know how to negotiate with the charging
station i'm being right up how to go and
pick a passengers and make you money
while you're not using it right and
these things I think resonate more with
people when you give them these really
solid examples of how machines need to
interact with other machines and do it
in a safe way on your behalf
right yeah in a way that's log it will
get to all that but I think that that
that simple idea of you going back and
not being able to get to somebody I
always wonder if there's a way to tell
the story yeah could get to that person
or those people that I I know I I wish
and I think that just happens over time
like you you tell your story in so many
different ways to so many different
people you start to pattern match what
kind of B classify the type of person
and how they'll respond to a particular
story right if you learn to tell like
different narratives to different
audiences so that they can begin to
understand and connect those dots along
with you I mean so I ended up going back
to my venture capital friends and they
were just like we have no idea what
you're talking about and I was like but
trillion dollar company whatever piques
their interest right how unicorn right
right and so what what do I do I go back
and I build another social network right
so I built something called backer where
like people who are crazy or geniuses or
both could put up their projects and and
build and build communities and build
audiences so that when they go to launch
products they have built-in audiences
right right there along lines of a
Kickstarter IndieGoGo yeah yeah it was
it so you had continuous crowdfunding
you had Kickstarter ask models inside of
it and it was just like I basically
mashed up everything that I've ever
learned from entrepreneurship and
building product into one product yeah
which was just like a beast yes like
well one of my friends is like when are
you gonna stop building features right
it's like I was just like okay cool and
when I was like working on the
newsletter feature for him like yeah it
was a it was a good time and go around
it is it is still up yeah ba q q ER
somebody asked me why I picked that name
I said because the domain was available
yeah and then working on that we start
going through okay
now I I have what I think is a license
to just start building what I want to
build right where I kind of look at this
as like a way to tell my story while I'm
building these things and we start out
with one of my friends who Adam Gibson
who does deep learning for Jay said
playa looks cool but people want
something to play with right so I ended
up starting to work on a prototype for a
wearable bot platform right imagine like
Alexa or Google home or what now Watson
I guess but in a wearable form that has
like a camera and sensors and here's
everything you hear sees everything you
see and starts documenting things right
hmm mm-hm and so we're prototyping that
out and we have our back-end which is
also cryptocurrency right - so how you
participate on the network you can build
applications and BOTS where people are
kind of creating this economy this
wearable data acquisition economy with
crypto as a back-end right so now humans
are kind of in this human-in-the-loop
data acquisition we kind of roll and we
went to this was before BOTS as a term
became popular which we were using
because previously BOTS as a term was
very like a nefarious thing right you
had like voting bots and you had you
know just like DDoS BOTS and and
whatever they were bad it was a bad
thing to label something about so we
were using the term autonomous
intelligent agent which I mean we'll put
anyone to sleep immediately so we went
to and then Facebook did their BOTS
thing and we went to the bots community
and we said hey look at this wearable
cool block platform that has a crypto
background this is before [ __ ] that was
even big right people were like cool I
have no idea what you're talking about
like we're like okay and we had to take
a step back and like how can we roll
something like this out in phases or
even how can we abstract it out the best
bits of this and and build it into a
network or a platform that people can
participate in on their own and make it
kind of like their own so we wanted to
become instead of the the front end like
iPhone or Google home we wanted to
become the the more like Twilio right or
platform or network where we're an
intermediary and we kind of unlock all
these things Horizonte for everyone else
to take advantage of so that's how we
came up with synapse we basically
abstract it out all the good stuff which
was the data and the machine learning
models and the decentralized network and
the crypto portion and we we luckily
enough we're able to bootstrap on top of
aetherium and so if you have any
background in crypto you understand that
aetherium offers smart contracts its
kind of has event-driven as an adventure
of a network where you can kind of
delegate services in some respects so
you have a bunch of different features
that what we're building kind of distant
mm-hmm fits right in and it unlocks the
ability to connect resources through a
marketplace right through the network so
we've been using the narrative of if
automation is coming right if it's if
it's party here and it is also going to
take over more then we should
participate right we should participate
and because of data lineage and because
of provenance
we should get rewarded right when these
models that we go to train get leveraged
so that was basically what we started
with and now I think the conversation
mmm is more revolved around we have
access to data we have access to machine
learning model we have all these
resources and we kind of built this
foundation and then we realized oh there
are even more emergent qualities right
that that that appear when you enable
these things so because we innovated
this AI blockchain thing we're able to
not just answer old questions right but
ask new ones which has been fascinating
like because you have provenance because
you have data lineage and you can see
who has access to what and when and how
you can create metamodels right of how
the network works and provide network
optimizations globally which starts to
look like a global autonomous logistics
and supply chain fascinating yeah yeah
so it's been one of my favorite things
to try and better understand about the
way the world works is where things
actually come from how they are actually
made how they get to you where you go
get them from when you consume them what
happens to them afterward that whole
process and we could do that now we can
we can literally do that by leveraging
than that this network right and maybe
we should chunk this up time at at the
time piece by piece sir all right so
let's go with a first piece the first
piece let's talk about decentralization
and blockchain technology so you had
started this aventures you were going in
trying to get more people more excited
about this fund the right companies so
in 2013 there were good amount of people
talking about the importance of the
centralization the importance of
cryptocurrency the importance of these
things
one only one of this probably the
biggest application is cryptocurrency of
decentralization but there's so many
other really important applications to
decentralization so centralization being
the way that you go into a bank and the
bank controls all of your funds and the
bank has their own digital ledger and
nobody else accesses of the digital
ledger versus the decentralization where
as a massive network of computers are
all keeping the digital ledger in a way
that incentivizes them to keep it
properly and so you having the
opportunity to see that four years ago
five years ago now and now seeing it
growing to the point that it is you kind
of saw the moment of capitalization
where you're gonna see all these
machines needing to talk to each other
and so you plugged right into the theory
'im way of the theorem network through
the theory and blockchains
and how those machines will be talking
to each other all the different services
and applications that are using the
theory of technology so let's go through
maybe some of the examples synapse is
currently used being used by the way
that synapse is helping other companies
and organizations yeah so the the first
feature is access control right so if
you announce the service or have some
access to data you can write the rules
by which you would like people to access
your data or resources on the blockchain
and that's the even the first one access
control right now I mean a really good
example I think people will resonate
with is when they give access to people
to gain part control over their Facebook
page right you get to give them admin
access you can give them just posting
access you can give them just x-axis
y-axis etc down on the the chain of
command
so access control is already really
interesting to the data so how much of
my personal data about my heart rate and
my other biometrics should a physician
be able to access about me right things
like this
right so you can kind of participate in
that way where you're doing one-on-one
transactions with your data or your
resources more abstractly or you can
participate in contract fulfilment so
you could say like these things are the
things that I'm willing to give away
right for particular research purposes
or even for monetary capitalization so
I'm willing to sell my data I'm willing
to give it for research purposes but
only this much access control right
right so you know we're thinking about
both your biometric data your genome
right all of your omics data but also
your transactional history like anything
that can be quantified in any way yeah I
mean we're just shedding that constant
constantly right so one of my favorite
quotes from a over a year ago now David
Ewing Duncan the second greatest
invention of mankind is all the data
that we leave behind and the first
greatest invention of mankind has yet to
be created and that's how do we analyze
that data and make it applicable to our
lives right and for example with giving
access control for financial records or
finding access control for research
organizations at Stanford of MIT
wherever to be able to use that for for
building a better future that seems like
something it's like a no-brainer like oh
you already give all of your access
control on your iPhone and on your
MacBook and on all these different
services on Facebook Twitter that you
your and give them you don't even read
the agreement - why not also you know
read the agreement and give a certain
amount of access so that we can make
health better health care better finance
is better a location data for maybe
police stations or for where we need to
build the next roads or build the next
hospitals or education institutes etc
yeah yeah absolutely the the the whole
concept that these these these companies
and body now
vertical right is is a monopoly around
the data because if they can monopolize
the data then they can monopolize the
models that go to create the data yeah
but unfortunately because they're
monopolies and they are businesses they
have a very targeted demographic
centralization rather which requires
them to participate in targeted
demographics which creates biased data
which creates biased models and so if
you have a way to participate in and
kind of creating a horizontal
marketplace for this data then you can
create more robust more representative
models yeah yeah something that I really
wanted to to get involved in was just an
idea like a year or more goes something
called like researcher where people
could give away biometric data um either
for charity or also for for money to
earn themselves and this is also an idea
for universal basic income as well do
does my data contain enough monetary
value for me to give a way to earn a
thousand dollars a month or two thousand
dollars a month the answer is probably
yes but right now the problem is all
your data that you own of yourself on
Facebook of the data that you own of
yourself on your Google account all the
own data you own of yourself on your all
your physician records all the stuff is
centralized in those separate locations
and you don't get any monetary ability
to tap into them and give bread yeah
it's it's kind of you do because the
service is free right but it's
interesting because they're able to
collect so much data and once they build
their models they kind of throw that
data away and it's your data you
generated its data to data about you and
you should be able to take that anywhere
you want to and I think the EU is doing
a really good job by they're going
through what GDP are which is data
protection rights and you're a they
basically say that people have to
participate
in data in such a way that the user owns
it and can take their data from services
what do you think about that I think
it's fantastic
DPR date of GDP GDP our general data
protection rights I think in GDP are
yeah yeah okay before we get there cuz
that's really fascinating
you had mentioned diversity and data
being really important and I and I
didn't want to miss that because that is
so crucial when you do get so many
people from around the world
contributing their data to a pool and
gives you easy easier ability for these
randomized controlled trials to be able
to produce a better world and then
without bias datasets right yeah you
right because bias data builds bias
models which perpetuate the bias implied
in the data yeah right so you see that
there's a good book and it's called I
think darn I just forgot it but it
basically talks about how data is used
perpetuate the the worst of machine
intelligence right and the worst of our
society because it exists to reflect
that right it's sampling that and it's
perpetuating that and it's it's kind of
insightful to see like that needs to be
the reason to decentralize it all right
that needs to be the reason to create a
horizontal marketplace to to create the
ability to query and have everyone
participate in a very democratic way to
contributing data to building machine
intelligence you you use the word
horizontal marketplace yeah that's so
interesting I have never heard of that I
like that yeah that seems to be the
answer not the vertical marketplaces
because there's why would Facebook have
any incentive to talk to Google so that
when you're in flow doing something that
you don't get Bing Bing Bing the message
right there's there's no incentive
between a bank to talk to your hospital
to talk to your educational institution
but there's so much beautiful data
fusion that could happen across those
platforms
yeah and we talked about it horizontally
because i-i've you it very horizontally
when we set out we wanted to be the data
and intelligence layer in this new stack
that's getting built so this new stack
web 3 that encompasses democratization
decentralisation and distributed storage
and compute it's all very horizontal
right and I think horizontal
marketplaces represent everyone equally
but also like when we imagine it it it
is something that will exist in every
device in every sensor all around the
world
right so we we use that phrase because
it it it matters and it means something
and once you're able to create this
horizontal marketplace people can
participate however they like to all
around the world right and if it takes
the focus less on the ownership of the
data from a company's perspective to how
can we build real utility from this data
exactly right and that's what's
important finding the utility right and
correlating that data between verticals
ok as well as you know then we can start
talking about well ok this is great
we're talking about data but what about
resources right what about machine
learning models what about autonomous
agents on this network where you can
have your Google home starting to talk
to your Alexa because they have a web of
trust now and they can contract one
another and you have control of your
data and your your transactional history
and your preferences and the models
about you is that this is the AI economy
plus the general data privacy right
right together right ok so let's unpack
this this guy this is gonna be very cool
so first of all this general data
privacy rights this seems to be the
future is ownership of data not by the
vertical marketplaces but by the
horizontal marketplace so I tap in I
give access control of how much I want
in and then the AI economy will
depending on which exact aspect of the
AI economy I want to tap into we
than autonomous cars example or any of
these different examples let's tell us
more about how exactly those are gonna
play in my access control and then the
AI economy you were kind of going into
some of those yeah so you need data to
train models that's it that's the
biggest problem with machine learning
today i people go oh great you want to
start a machine learning company you
have no access to data right and that's
the monopoly that's why these companies
want to own everything down to the last
mile down to your phone down to your
home right there's no real sharing
because sharing means they don't have an
advantage anymore right and so if we're
able to create this this horizontal
marketplace and we're able to
participate in in the ways that we're
talking about now the data is is open
right and and not not open in a way that
it means I'm insecure door not private
but open in that it's addressable yeah
right and so now you're able to perform
contract fulfillment to train these
models to to actually access an entire
globe full of data like that's Google
can't do that alone
Amazon can't do that alone Facebook
can't do that alone right so we're
unlocking this whole new like resource
and potential of people participating in
a brand new way to train bigger more
robust models which is is fascinating it
is but you need to get the big players
behind it you do and they are they are
willing to work together so I I won't
mention anything but we have some pretty
big companies we just through the
decentralized AI summit here in February
we had everyone from Google Microsoft
Amazon Samsung Qualcomm Nvidia I mean
the big players the independent
researchers that are thinking about
decentralize the I am very particular
verticals like healthcare we had you
know people who were just like working
in AI exclusively come out and start
talking about this is a way that we can
start
implementing these pieces on the network
and how we're applying AI now and it it
will it was a huge success right we we
actually started a month beforehand I
was like you know what we should do
we should throw a conference and much to
everyone that works with me is this May
they were like okay yeah when does it
need to get done in 30 days great and we
pulled it off we had over 375 attendees
and this was at the Fairmont Hotel we
hacked des good of just killer we had
the the founder of the SETI program
search for extraterrestrial he kid has a
lot about SETI in general cares a lot
about figuring out how to leverage AI to
better find life in the universe and
NASA really needs that for their
exoplanet data there's there's a lot
that's and there's a distributed
computer component too which is really
exciting because we're talking about
building out this horizontal marketplace
of resources you need kind of the power
to match building something like a
global brain right and that's that's why
we were really excited to bring all
these people together because the they
are literally just puzzle pieces and in
solving this future that we're working
toward but so they agreed at the summit
to do global compute which i think is a
little bit easier to agree to do but for
Amazon to open up their book their data
sets so that Google can learn from them
and that Google opens their so Amazon
can learn from them that's not yet so
they're figuring it out and I think
things like GDP are I think that's
headed for the US but it's crazy because
GDP are that general data and privacy
rights that that doesn't there's no
incentive for them to open up their ass
did they have to they almost have to see
a monetary incentive in order to open up
so there has to be some sort of grand
vision of when you do merge your little
vertical is actual
look like a joke compared to the grande
set that you're gonna be able to make
twice as much off of right that would be
and if you have more data you can create
better models and the more data that you
like create corollaries from right and
combine your data to to find better
insights the better your products can be
so Amazon would love to participate
because Amazon would love to target
things that you actually want like I
think ads are kind of this weird stopgap
of like discovery for people and trying
to figure out what people want and and
trying to figure out where the product
fits but if you're able to understand
somebody I mean we've seen you know
talks where the machine learning models
after a hundred likes can figure you out
better than your significant other right
but imagine doing that for a lifetime
right imagine what insights you can find
out then and then you you have what
begins to start look looking like a very
predictive world so there's a model
that's absorb we learn to predict and
then influence so if you can if you can
create predictive models around a single
person that's where everyone wants to be
mmm right if you can make my life easier
take my money right and I think that's
that's where people want to be no one
wants to sell somebody something they
don't need or want right and nobody
wants to participate in something that
they have kind of regrets or remorse
participate people don't want to have
their package deliver to an incorrect
location right and then they have to
drive to the incorrect location Rob Ron
and I had like a 200-foot SDI cable or
two 100 for the SDI cables shipped to
hmm in downtown at Union Square during
our big World's Fair Nano event and so
we actually go on the Friday before to
go to H&M to go get it so it just stuff
like this is so funny people don't want
to invest that additional time you want
they want their life to be simpler so
prediction right is what really makes
their life more simple I'm about to run
out of almond milk
mm-hmm oh great now it's shipped to my
house the day that I run out perfect
right there are so many examples of this
I'm about to go to my meeting with Dan
at his office and it's gonna take me 20
minutes to get there
so the car is waiting outside 22 minutes
before the meeting starts right and I'm
getting into the car and going in that's
just there's so much beauty in this
prediction right and it helps us reclaim
the probably the most important resource
of all which is time yeah which is cool
so you know going back to why these big
companies will want to participate
because if they don't no one will use
them they won't be appealing anymore
they won't have an advantage by not
participating right the advantage now
becomes participating which will allow
them to concentrate on things that
matter which are experiences and the
technology that goes in to provide those
new experiences so that's that's kind of
like the big vision yeah right and
that's why they have to get involved
right so especially with these
Millennials in the Jen's ears a
millennial there we're not there's no
there's no way that you're gonna get
Millennials and Gen zere's no I think
really no matter how much value that you
proposed to them and that they get from
you if you're not under the same general
data and privacy rights as as other
organizations are I think the tide is
turning yeah I I really do think that
there are more and more people that are
becoming aware of the power of data the
value of data and are looking to figure
out okay if there's these large
companies that can create these very
impactful very powerful models around
who we are what we are what we enjoy
well what else can we do that furthers
and benefits mankind humankind as a
whole and I think that's kind of we're
starting to see that message come out
and so it won't just be something that
you like to participate in I think it'll
become an imperative that you
participate in this because it means
something good for everyone
simultaneously yeah and that's just and
that's just talking about the data and
talking about the research we're not
even getting into what programmatic
access to this means and like how that
unlocks this whole new AI economy and
then what even AI means in the grand
scheme of humanity and it's you know
place in the world or the universe this
has been episode one will be back with
episode 2 in two weeks who will jump
this up in two sessions yeah what what
else yeah what are we missing out of the
equation you just mentioned a couple of
them let's talk about those I'll talk
about a few pretty quickly and it it is
the comes back to the philosophy of why
I'm building this right it's like it's
satisfied so many things simultaneously
where it's it's great for Humanity it's
the only way forward in some respects
yeah and it's it unlocks kind of these
new questions that we can ask but it
simultaneously it also provides the the
conduit for building autonomous
artificial intelligence that can start
helping us ask and answer questions
about the world around us and I have a
very different view of what AI will be
common how it fits in our lives and I
look at it as the the code X between
disparate systems so different systems
yeah yeah that's that's cool um a lot of
people think about it in a single way of
helping me in a single part of life than
a different and different part of life
but the actual communication between
those two verticals right yeah that's
that's magical that's when that's when
things start moving towards like not
just like me and the things around me
but me and the things around me and how
I understand both myself and those
things relative to everything else in
the world and I think it's really kind
of the the ingredient necessary for
evolution datasets to talk to the open
datasets and open datasets and the
artificial intelligence that goes to
find these insights yes I was working on
a concept
called proof within sight where we're
using consensus and autonomous research
laboratories I mean so my background is
as a scientist and I think you know
taking out humans out of the equation
while we are good at some of these
things I think it's necessary right to
find because we're biased yes yeah
to find science and the instructions so
if you look at science science is
looking for observations too to kind of
quantit quantifying and qualify the the
working world and instructions within
the universe there's been so many smart
people that have sat in the chair right
there that have said that they don't
want the human out of the loop mmm
I'm just I love and appreciate how you
want the human out of the loop I think
for some things it's it's necessary I
don't think that they shouldn't be able
to be in the loop but if they are in the
loop then their work should be checked
so you're going into objectivity and
you're going into the scientific method
right there
right so you really want these open
datasets to have for us to be analyzing
them to train algorithms that can
analyze them and then in a non as a non
biased way as possible and then for it
to learn over time across these data
sets and make insights and predictions
great entirely I think it is super
important that we figure out systems to
create knowledge that matters and
knowledge that isn't influenced or
biased in in any particular way yeah
representative knowledge and then how do
we catalog that and store and retrieve
that in ways where we can leverage that
knowledge to grow new systems right and
I think that this is this is kind of
like so to talk like blue sky about
these things about how we can build a
eyes that discover natural systems that
we can't observe because we are
naturally inclined to have some blind
spots because we are these organisms I
think it it matters so much that we
allow artificial intelligence to do what
it's good at which is not being human
to help us to learn how to be more human
yeah and understand what it means to be
human within this system within the
universe it's yeah it's it strikes me is
like the most magic place possible you
know because if we know about ourselves
truly then I think that's the end of
things like war and things like hate and
you know the a new age of love and
appreciation and discovery we've had a
lot of people also come in here and talk
about love and connection and peace and
a new era of humanity and all these on
all the time yeah also crazy that they
come in here with the intention of
sharing their ideas without the without
the with in a different way than you are
you're doing it in a very youth you
think that we're gonna get there with
the power of things like decentralized
AI networks and I think that we will
absolutely get there with that power I
think that will provide us with some
insight into the into peace and more
collective and progressive thoughts and
then I think other things like
meditation and spirituality can get us
there I think that other things like
human connectivity and just human touch
get us there there's a lot of different
things that that get us there but yeah
yeah I I don't think that it's one or
the other right altogether I think the
more we discover the truth the more we
can start participating in the truth and
so tell okay so we what was what was the
main like pillar of the decentralized AI
network what is the thing that most
people are using it for in our access
control so access control and the
marketplace so in the horizontal
marketplace right those are the two main
players okay so we have companies
talking to us about how they can help
provide the infrastructure for
distributed compute how you know there's
hold
companies that are talking to us that
are concerned about IOT that are
concerned about their data and that are
concerned about how to leverage a
network like this to participate because
they're already thinking globally their
their telecom companies that literally
connect the world already right and
they're thinking okay we have the
infrastructure for this how do we build
something that enables us to leverage
that infrastructure and in new and
exciting and insightful ways and so the
conversations are already here it's not
a matter of when I mean the marketplace
is built we're already starting to build
the the wallets and how people
participate on the network we're already
starting to talk about companies who
want to participate in the ecosystem
with I mean ginormous resources so yeah
it's it's coming so okay so we have
access control we have horizontal
marketplaces and the companies that are
coming to you a lot of them are asking
you about how they can take there so how
they can participate in contributing
data how they can leverage data and new
and exciting ways so that's been the the
first concept I can't go in and talk
about like oh well once you decode the
the instructions of the universe right
then mankind and every person and being
inside of it will find love
great but first you need to build up
these AI economies right you you need to
to leverage these resources to kind of
get it's like steering a giant boat you
have to get out somewhere and start
small and it's about the data and how
people can get access to the data and
creating this marketplace performing
contract fulfillment event-driven
networks where you have everyone across
the globe being able to listen to
delegated events of like someone needs
this kind of data or this kind of
resource yeah right and so that's very
practical okay that's a very practical
first step to saying okay now we're
gonna start building in some AI
components that have agency over these
resources that can start contracting
with gonna one another
and optimizing paths through
Network and giving them their ability to
create their own new emergent economies
inside of this network and those are all
very easy to understand things and then
show you why I guess so you know I've
been thinking about it for so long it's
like it's been it's been a wild ride but
you know I think that's that's kind of
the first step and then you start
talking about okay well if you have a
network that is able to acquire this
data and acquire this knowledge what do
you do with that how do you build
metamodels you know there's a ton of
ways like I said we want to be the
platform that enables kind of these are
basically ideas if you're watching at
home work on this stuff we have the
ability for people you know anywhere
around the world to create a new kind of
machine learning model in some new way
that displaces everything and in some
new and fascinating way right that that
goes to to build a better world and has
autonomy over you know its resources and
and can transact with other agents
across the network I think that's that's
the beauty of what we start unlocking is
is democratizing access to to really
make things cool
holy cow this is this is big it is I'm
really happy that you're building it
into our world and you're doing with
such passion enthusiasm and your how big
is the company now so we were actually
pretty small so we're like seven people
we're looking to hire all the time so if
you're who are you looking to hire
awesome hackers right I've been
programming since I was 10 it would be
nice if we got some other cool hackers
in yeah
hey I experts we've been partnering with
some research labs that previously
worked with Google Open AI and are
helping us build proof of concept models
for other companies to leverage with
their data things like that so if you're
a data scientist if you're into big data
if you're in the edge computing
distributed compute machine learning and
AI in general I think that those are the
kind of people that we're looking for to
start thinking about this and by the way
we're not the first people to start
thinking about this right actually I
would save the whole entire there's a
whole entire sci-fi book shelf somewhere
that's just like this right you know we
didn't come up with the idea of ambient
intelligence that that's been around for
a long time
people have been thinking about this in
bits and pieces from cybernetics and and
conversation theory and and like all of
these things that kind of are converging
on this future we just happened to be at
the right place in the right time to
kind of start unlocking a lot of these
things with you know both machine
learning edge computing all the sensors
that we have aetherium like blockchain
and crypto it's like literally the the
best place in time to be to see all
these things kind of come to fruition
and I imagine it must have been like
what early personal computers felt like
or early internet felt like it's just
yeah you're on the verge yeah so
you mentioned cybernetics it really goes
hand in hand with decentralized AI
networks it does when you think about so
Norbert Wiener was the huffman hopefully
I'm pronouncing the last name ago was a
father of cybernetics which is
essentially control systems for any
engineers out there and they talk about
second-order cybernetics and at one
point I tried to use second-order IOT
and people were just like no please
please don't
whatever that means like just stop and
they were talking about incoming and
they were talking about second-order
cybernetics which is like systems that
watch systems and they were really
starting to think of these things in
terms of like the precursors to kind of
modern AI right you have a Ventura Bush
that was thinking about knowledge and
knowledge repos and storage and
retrieval knowledge and you just have a
bunch of these people that that started
building out the basis for where we're
heading to today and like we stand on
the shoulders of giants
you know I I'm just lucky I think yeah
but likewise am I to have the privilege
to sit next to brilliant people that are
building the future and discuss with
them what exactly is going on yeah this
is this is super super insightful what
are what are we doing on time right now
No
what are we doing on time okay and how
close are we to seven perfect so we'll
take like 15 more and then we'll get you
into the photo go portrait photo so
seven yeah yeah so we have time
well I want to run you through all of
our simulation questions but it's so
difficult to get there when this one
what you're building is so exciting
especially I just I can't get over all
these relatable examples can you give us
like the main I know it's so hard to
come up with like the main example when
there is when it's being leveraged for
so many different things but what's like
the most applicable one that I'm using
today I think what this enables is a you
know one of the things that I've worked
on was a yeah how do I put this we're
like if I can rephrase the question
would be like which data sets which data
sets are currently being open sourced to
where we're able to analyze and make a
prediction into our lives that is really
relatable today so right now a really
great one and a partner that's that's
coming on and I won't i won't name a
name yet but genetic data so genetic
data is super cool I just had my whole
genome sequence great it's it's sub one
about various sub one thousand seven one
thousand dollars and your that it's a
Veritas as a great service and you know
I I think that there's so much potential
there I have a view had your genome
sequence dead well so I got my report in
I'm twenty-five percent Native American
by the way that's pretty pretty neat my
mom didn't even know that was
interesting
whoa yeah and they they had a report
that was full of insights like that I'm
very particular to are very annoyed by
people that queue what their mouths open
how do they know apparently there was a
research done and or that I'm very
sensitive to the smell of stinky feet
right but and so you can create you can
map genotype to phenotype to more
emergent qualities right like like what
you prefer like your preferences your
your psychological profile you are
your predilection towards sweets like
anything whoa
right and imagine that level of insight
right over time you'll be able to create
a whole adaptive system of the one day
you'll be born with bots that know
everything about you know your capacity
know how to how to teach you how you
learn will be your best friend your
mentor yep and and help you reach the
potential you want to read much faster
than we might live in in today's rattled
yeah holy cow so I didn't know that
genomic data gave all of those insights
yeah whoa yeah okay and the more
insights we have of all of those that
ohmic data as well as like you know the
rest of our lives the more we can start
figuring out and connecting those dots
of like okay this connects to this
phenotype or this genotype and and it's
it's all there it's all coded inside of
us right I'm loving the idea of knowing
right at the point of
inception of this child that's being
born and knowing a lot about it and then
being able to hand it off to a very
intelligent bot that can give it
valuable insights throughout its life
because right now a lot of parents fail
miserably and a lot of parents do okay
and some parents do well it's very
difficult to find outstanding parents
outstanding parents are really rare and
there are certain benefits that come
from falling on your face a lot right
but at the same time but just enough
just enough yeah not overly you don't
want to do it so much you give up or die
you want to do it enough where you learn
and you're able to continue and we
resilient Alyssa that makes you stronger
stronger yeah I'm very fascinated by
weed you know we just had been a48 on
our show along with Bruce Duncan Billy
berry and they're working on ice gas
most new teachers and the idea that I
can come home to a bot that understands
me and how I'm feeling and what I want
to learn that evening and walks me
through and guides me as my teacher and
mentor mmm I love that and to have that
from birth and a hand in that world okay
let's let's let's run you through this
question to start okay how do we program
ethics
ethics into all of this yeah I think wow
what a what a great hard question
ultimately I think it comes down to you
know can can we build a system that
allows us to - it depends on what
aspects of ethics we're talking about if
we're talking about personal ethics and
and if we're talking about adaptive
learning agents that help us grow up and
kind of imbue their own philosophies and
and help shape our view of the world
then we can talk about ethics in that
respect right the ethics that machine's
reflect into us or we can which
inevitably doesn't mean that it's the
ethics that the machines hold but that
that the ethics that they think we
require so how do we there's two
questions there how do we guarantee that
the machines themselves are ethical and
how do we guarantee that the ethics that
we learn by interacting with the
machines are things that we would like
to imbue ourselves with that is such a
difficult question because what what is
good and bad right and and the relative
to to who we are what is truth right
because you need truth to understand
what is good and bad right and so you
can't just decide what is good and bad
without knowing the truth so I think you
need to build a system that can
understand the truth before it can
decide what is good and bad but to
decide what is good and bad for any
particular system that is alive in the
universe it must understand perhaps the
intent of the universe which is
difficult I would say very difficult so
ethics ultimately is something that is
unknown and only relative to the systems
that are talking about it okay so let's
lead that into our next question because
if the ethics need to be guided by the
universe then I know that time what
we're meaning and the purpose correct
okay so then what is the meaning and
purpose of life or the universe oh that
no one knows and and I use the analogy I
mean to even begin thinking about the
purpose of something that grand is like
a vacuum trying to read Shakespeare we
just don't have the the faculties to
even begin to understand what that could
quite possibly be give me your best
approximation
some people said the universes objection
our objective is to create more entropy
you know so create more disorder yeah
which is fascinating because gestation
creates order right gestation creates
order sure so to create a human being or
to create another life is is not is is a
collection of order right it is but then
it also is disorders or not as well it
is a collection of order is a collection
okay to create an ordered system that
then goes on to create perhaps disorder
yeah right and maybe that's the
University oh I have enough capacity to
build these additional elites of order
that create even more direct right so so
maybe we're just that right now but I
don't know that's just one idea how
about how about on our rock or go ahead
yeah but I do think and this is kind of
I do think that it is perhaps our
purpose to build AI yeah no I know and
I'll get into that because
philosophically speaking or just
observational II speaking human kind is
very good at identifying systems
muddling those systems and then building
tools to leverage those models to create
efficiencies out of systems right and we
realize that that model is itself a
system right and we can model that which
is what we've done by creating a system
which is a tool like computers and
calculators and things kind of do what
man does right mankind does and we then
created AI we then created AI because AI
can then start to accomplish some of
these tasks right similar to how we kind
of observe the world and ultimately
providing some intelligence that can go
to participate in the universe in this
way is is it almost feels like because
we can perhaps might mean it is meant to
be which is weird
that we engage in a system that has
these instructions that facilitates us
you know in in its system and we feel
obligated to create this this thing
right and it's not just about the
efficiencies but also about the
eradication of suffering right and it's
also about discovery exploration
understanding and so perhaps the
universe has created everything inside
of it to facilitate this next phase
which will help everything else inside
of it understand themselves yeah yeah
well said all right and then how about
what is one thing that you believe to be
true that do you think nobody else
believes to be true
well every year there's a new thing that
I I have not heard people say that it is
part of our our evolution and our
purpose to build AI maybe I need to talk
to more people I agree I don't hear that
that often yeah
very rarely actually do I hear that yeah
yeah previously I would say that my view
on AI is about artificial intelligence
connecting disparate systems and acting
as a codecs between it so one day I said
we could talk to the bees and we can
understand you know mmm I would say talk
to the stars because it's more fantastic
you know right yeah and things like that
and and I think those were the two big
things that I would say that people are
like oh that's crazy yeah but now that
people have built kind of you know deep
learning machine learning models to talk
to dolphins it doesn't seem that crazy
yeah III would agree with you on the
ladder I think that that is definitely a
very very rare perspective of being able
to talk to the pants psychist
perspective to be able to talk to all
other things that have even a couple
neurons and to tap into the global
consciousness and then the